a lot of people when you started out you
know you took the jobs that came along
that you could get absolutely and you
were happy to have them that's right and
and then people forget you become don
cheadle and they forget that you were in
Fresh Prince yeah you were you were ice
tray I was ice tray I think we have a
photograph here of you an ice tray and
that's you mentioned that to people
they're like oh cool Fresh Prince of Bel
Air yeah that's that's that's cool yeah
that was long that was the second
episode of the show really yeah
yet second episode it was why it was
will was still mouthing everybody else's
lines so I said yep you do a scene with
him because he was so inexperienced at
that time I was brand they do a scene
with him and he'd be saying your lines
they said don't do is I gonna get got it
and they do it again and he was fine and
you said to him I promise you you'll
never make it in this business I didn't
buy that I said you're a loser and it's
over but it was after that after that
second episode I got a pilot they said
we want to do a pilot we wanted you know
based around you and it was kind of a
crazy experience and we shot a pilot and
it never got on the air the Pioneers
this is where you were gonna be I stray
I actually know they changed the
character the pilot was called in the
house they went later they gave that
title to LL Cool J show in the house and
he did that right
so yeah NBC was for a minute they were
gonna be my champions and then Brandon
Tartikoff left and Warren do you guys
have what all this minutia no no Brandon
Tartikoff one of the great broadcasting
geniuses of all time that's right he was
the president there and then he left and
Warren Littlefield came in and then
Warren Littlefield works he canceled the
show so that didn't get to go but you
did make another show it was a spinoff
that's right of the golden girl correct
and hardly anybody remembers did you
watch it was right when I first came to
LA it was like one of my first big
auditions right which old lady were you
going to be I was a chef with an accent
yeah I remember correctly yeah you know
who got your part No Cheech Marin which
is you and Cheech Marin be up with the
same and I have probably gone up yeah
we've gone up a bunch of things yeah
that's tragic it's a Golden Girls
spin-off and I had forgotten about it
but it's called we found an ad it was
called Golden Palace it's of course and
it was it was the other Bea Arthur
wasn't in it but the others were in it
ladies were there and we have this
picture of a real ad and go tell the
customers aren't the only ones with
reservation yeah and I love that you've
got I mean you've proven yourself as an
actor 10,000 times over and won every
award you can get and then you had to do
this what am I gonna do with these
ladies yeah my idea that was what was
your character I was rolling the hotel
manager mm-hm and they all moved to
Miami and bought a hotel and I came with
the hotel I guess right right I have
found this this isn't a joke as is true
I have found it's the jobs that you
don't get early on that save you or the
jobs that don't work out right right
yeah that that it's whether a job you
didn't get or something you desperately
wanted thought this is gonna be my
chance and it doesn't work out and at
the moment you think you know no that's
it that's it it's not gonna happen for
me and then look at everything you've
done since that maybe couldn't have
happened if that show had gone nine
years yeah and you and it's so true you
never know and it's like the the roles
that you took that you know you see
people go oh you were in that and you're
kind of embarrassed about it's like that
day you got that job you were like
[Laughter]
we're gonna get your rent paid yeah and
you are excited about exactly